Bitte schön.
Guten Morgen. Mein Name ist Dr. Renes Erdwöck. Ich bin der für Sie zuständige Arzt in dieser Station.
Und jetzt möchte ich mit Ihnen aus einem Gespräch durchführen.
Aber bevor wir anfangen, muss ich Ihre persönliche Daten aufnehmen. Sind Sie damit zu lachen?
Gerne. Bitte schön.
Okay. Wie heißen Sie ich?
Mein Name ist Paul.
Paul Bau.
Herr Baum, können Sie bitte Ihre Vor- und Nachnamen buchstabieren?
Mein Nachnamen ist Baum. Wieder Baum.
Okay.
Vorname ist Paul. P-A-U-L.
Okay, klar. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 30 Jahre alt.
30.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 1. September.
1903.
Okay, Herr Baum. Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin ungefähr 1,75 groß.
1,75 groß?
Ich würde circa 75 Kilogramm.
75 Kilogramm?
75.
Okay, alles klar. Herr Baum, was kann ich so sehen?
Ich habe seit ungefähr 2 Tagen Schmerzen auf der rechten Seite.
2 Tage Schmerzen auf der rechten Seite.
Auf der rechten Seite ist Körper.
Genau. Also Rechte Bauchseite.
Rechte Bauchseite, okay.
Seit 2 Tagen.
Und Rechte Bauchseite.
Wie haben die Schmerzen begonnen? Langsam oder plöstlich?
Langsam, ganz langsam haben die angefangen, nachts.
Und werden jetzt immer stärker.
Im Laufe der Seite haben die Schmerzen sich verstanden, ja?
Genau.
Okay, können Sie bitte Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind Sie zum Beispiel brennend, stechend, dumpfartig?
Das sind so dumpferartige Schmerzen, die immer wieder kommen und gehen.
Ach so, kommen die Schmerzen als Attacken, ja?
Genau.
Okay, dann Ihre Schmerzen sind verübergreifend und kommen als Attacken.
Und wie oft kommt eine Attacke?
Hab ich jetzt nicht erzählt.
Okay.
Und wie lange dauert eine Attacke des Schmerz?
Ungefähr so 2-3 Minuten.
3 Minuten.
Okay. Können Sie bitte Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerz, die Kalafon 1 bis 10 einschätzen?
1 bedeutet sehr leichte Schmerz, 7 bedeutet unerträgliche Schmerz.
Ja, so 7-8 würde ich sagen.
Und ich würde Sie fragen, Schözralen Ihre Schmerzen, wie geht es wohin aus?
In die Leiste ein bisschen, in die Leistung unter den Rücken.
In der Leistung unter den Rücken, ja.
Okay, in der Leistung, in der rechte Leistung, oder?
Rechte Leistung unter den Rücken, ja.
Okay.
Gibt es eine bestimmte Auslösung für die Schmerzen, zum Beispiel Essen, Trinken, Bewegung?
Nee, eigentlich nicht.
Keine Auslösung, okay.
Und gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen lindert oder verschlimmert?
Schmerzmedikamente.
Verstellt das Ihre Schmerzen?
Verlösst.
Okay, Schmerzmedikamente.
Ich habe schon ganz medikamente genommen.
Ich habe Ibuprofen genommen.
Wie viel Milligramm?
600 Milligramm.
Ich habe schon bestimmt 10 Stück genommen.
10 Stück?
Bestimmt, 2 Tage, ja.
2 Tage, okay.
Aber es scheint so viel, ja.
Ja, aber ich habe das nicht ausgehalten.
Es war viel.
Okay.
2, 2, 10 Stück.
Herbauen.
Soll ich Ihnen jetzt ein Schmerzmedikament geben oder können Sie Ihre Schmerzen ausraten bis Ende unseres Gesprächs?
Ich kann das noch ein bisschen aushalten.
Okay, sehr gut.
Nach einem Namen von Ibuprofen hat andere Beschwerden aufgetrieben, als die Bewilligungen usw.
Ja, ich habe das ja.
Die 10 Stück Ibuprofen ist ein bisschen viel, ja, für 2 Tage.
Deswegen habe ich sie gebracht.
Ja, aber ich habe sehr stark Schmerzen gehabt.
Die haben geholfen, ja.
Okay, okay.
Aber jetzt habe ich keine Sablette mehr.
Okay, ja.
Okay, Herr Baum, fühle Sie sich pfiblich?
Ja, eigentlich schon.
Und habe Sie schon gemessen?
Ja, ich habe leider keine Fiebermaske dazu.
Okay.
Und leiden Sie gleichzeitig unter Schüttefrost oder nach Zwei, Kaltenschweiz?
Ja, so ein bisschen ist mir das aufgefallen, ja.
Schüttefrost?
Ja, so ein bisschen Zittern habe ich.
Zittern, okay.
Und leiden Sie unter, erschwitzen Sie mehr als früher?
Oder tagsüber?
Ja, wenn die Attacken kommen, ne?
Also wenn die Schmerzattacken kommen, ja, dann ja.
Okay.
Bei Schmerzattacken erschwitzen Sie.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Ja.
Okay.
Und müssten Sie sich übergeben, wenn Ihnen übel war?
Ja, schon zweimal.
Zweimal Erbruch.
Okay.
Okay, Herr Baum.
Wie sieht der Erbruch aus?
Das weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber.
Und wer dautus ist, ja?
Ja.
Und haben Sie bemerkt, dass es ein Blut in Ihrem Erbruch gibt?
Hab ich nicht gesehen, nein.
Okay.
Trinken Sie genug Wasser?
Ich hoffe ja, also so, mindestens ein Liter am Tag.
Okay.
Ich habe nicht gesehen, dass Sie 1,5 Liter Wasser trinken könnten.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Ja, ich habe in den zwei Tagen nicht viel gestern.
Also zwei Tagen habe ich wenig gestern, kann sein als bis ab oder mal.
Was weiß ich?
Sie haben Appetitusigkeit wegen Schmerz?
Ja, ich denke schon.
Okay.
Trinken Sie beim Wasserlassen oder beim Sturrgang?
Schäwigkeiten auf?
Nein.
Okay.
Und haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Ja, ich habe noch eine Beschwerden.
Ich habe noch eine Beschwerden, die ich in diesem Sommer lang etwas ein, das wichtig sein könnte.
Das war es.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme ein oder durchzuschlafen?
Ja, wegen Schmerzen jetzt.
Wegen Schmerzen.
Ja, wegen Schmerzen.
Okay.
Haben Sie vorständig geimpft?
Ich denke schon, ja.
Gut.
Waren Sie im letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Nein.
Okay.
Bleiben Sie Sport?
Fahrradfahren, spazieren gehen.
Und ich habe noch eine Frage.
Träten Ihre Schmerzen
nach oder vor dem Essen auf oder?
Nein.
Sind bei Ihnen Allergien oder Unterträglichkeiten weg?
Nicht das Wurst.
Kein Anergen.
Trauchen Sie Herbau?
Nein.
Nein, super.
Trinken Sie auch noch?
Noch nicht, vielleicht war ich am.
Nein, okay.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Zelt.
Was meinen Sie damit?
Weil ich Feier in die Brüder rausgekriegt habe.
Okay, gelegentlich.
Gelegentlich.
Okay.
Jetzt würde ich nach Ihrer Folge Geschichte fragen.
Bleiben Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Kein.
Okay.
Würden Sie schon einmal operieren?
Meine Mandeln sind raus.
Mandeln? Entfernung?
Ja, als Kind.
Als Kind.
Okay.
Herbau, lebe Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja.
Und leiden Ihre Eltern an chronischen Erkrankungen?
Sie haben beide Bluthochdruck und Diabetes.
Ein oder Typ-Syri-Diabetes?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Nicht wichtig.
Okay.
Bluthochdruck und Diabetes, beides.
Genau, beide.
Okay.
Hab es ihr geschwistert?
Nein, ich bin ein Einzelkind.
Ein Einzelkind, okay.
Nehmen Sie Medikamente regelmäßig ein.
Irgendwas.
Ich werde nicht, ich bin Profin.
Nein, ich werde nicht.
Wenn ich Beschwerden habe.
Bye, Bedar.
Genau.
600 Milligramm Hab es ihr gesagt habt?
Ja, genau, die hatte ich von meinem Arzt bekommen.
Okay.
Litten Sie unter diesem Beschwerden bereits einmal oder das erste Mal?
Das erste Mal.
Okay.
Medikamente.
Was sind Sie von Beurot, Herbau?
Ich bin Programmierer.
Programmierer?
Wie ein Informatiker?
Genau.
Okay, haben Sie Probleme auf Ihrer Arbeit, diese Belastung?
Eigentlich nicht.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihre Familienzüchter?
Ich bin ledig.
Ledig?
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Wohnen Sie alleine oder damit?
Ich wohne allein.
Okay.
Was mir aufgefallen ist, ist auch, dass ich ein bisschen Brenn beim Wasserlasten habe.
Ach so, Bibliothek Wasserlasten?
Ja, das ist mir auch aufgefallen.
Okay.
Wasserlasten.
Müssen Sie nachts auf die Toilette gehen?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Aber ich habe nicht auf die Toilette gehen.
Was haben Sie?
Okay.
Wasserlasten ist weniger geworden, oder?
Ja.
Müssen Sie öfter auf die Toilette gehen als früher?
Nein, schon.
Ja, okay.
Was haben Sie?
Okay.
Wasserlasten.
Wie sieht Ihre Öl aus?
Ja, dunkel, so konzentriert.
Konzentriert?
Ja.
Licht Ihrer Öl.
Wie riecht Ihre Öl?
Hab ich nicht dran gerochen.
Okay.
Dunkel.
Ja, Herr Baum, ich glaube, ich habe...
Ich habe keine Dusche.
Ja, okay.
Klar.
Okay. Sie haben kein Problem mit dem Stullgang.
Nein.
Okay, gut.
Okay, Herr Baum, ich habe alle wichtige Informationen gesammelt.
Und...
Ich habe keine Probleme mit dem Stullgang.
Ja, okay.
Sehr gut.
Ich habe...
Ich habe vergessen.
Ja.
Sie sehen...
Sportlich und gesund, die Schafe.
Kein...
Brauchen, nicht brauchen.
Einst brauchen.
Sehr sehr gut.
Ja, sehr gut.
Sehr gut.
Okay, Herr Baum.
Ja, jetzt würde ich Sie
über weitere Schritte informieren.
Ja.
Ich möchte Sie jetzt körperlich untersuchen
und dann
Blutab nehmen.
Ihnen Blutab nehmen.
Und danach,
wenn
falls Sie
Wasserlasten
können, bestimmen wir Ihre
Übelstätung.
Und danach
kann ich Ihnen sagen, worunter Sie leiten
und was wir machen.
Haben Sie denn schon einen Verdacht,
was es sein könnte?
Ja, ich gehe von
einer
Entzündung
der
Handweg
aus.
Ja, meine Veranstaltung
ist
eine Entzündung
der
Handlings, zum Beispiel
Handrohrer, Handleiter und so weiter.
Aber das ist eine neue Veranstaltung
je nach Befund,
kann ich Ihnen genauer sagen.
Verstanden.
Und deswegen...
Anders als wenn
das in den Bauch wehtut,
das musst du doch in den
unteren, in der Haarblase wehtun
oder ich habe Beschmerzen
ja oben rechts ein bisschen.
Ja, es könnte
zum Beispiel die
Entzündung der
Neure verursacht
auch solche
Symptome, aber
wie gesagt, habe,
muss ich
es zuerst ein paar Untersuchungen
durchführen. Und danach besprechen wir
wieder.
Muss ich denn hierbleiben oder kann ich
hierbleiben
bis wir Ihre Diagnose
bestätigen können.
Okay.
Nein, machen Sie
kleine Sorge.
Meine Veranstaltung
wenn ich meine Veranstaltung bestätige,
dann kann ich Ihre
Beschwerden
heilen.
Okay.
Danke schön.
Danke.
Okay.
Ja, Guten Tag mein Oberarzt.
Wenn Sie im Moment Zeit hätten, würde ich Sie meinen Patienten vorstellen.
Gerne, bitte schön.
Es geht um Herr Paul Baum, der 30 Jahre alt, 1,70 m groß
und 75 kg schwer sein.
Er stellte sich bei uns, wegen seit 2 Tagen,
dummartiger und starker Schmerzen im rechten Bauch vor
und die Schmerzen hätten im Laufe der Zeit festgekommen.
Und die Schmerzen seien übergehend und kommen als Ataken.
Ein Ataker dauert ungefähr 2 oder 3 Minuten.
Und die Schmerzen im Oberbauch oder im Unterbauch?
Unterbauch.
Was denn jetzt?
Sicher?
Ich habe es nicht gefragt.
Ich habe eine leichte Oberbauchseite.
Müssen Sie fragen, Unterbauch oder Oberbauch?
Ja, wir haben recht.
Die Schmerzen würden in der rechten Leiste und Rücken ausgestrahlen.
Und dem Patienten zufolge liegt die Schmerzintensität auf einer Schmerzkala
von 1 bis 10, bei 7 oder 8.
Und der Patienten sagte, dass es kein Auslöse für die Schmerzen gab.
Und dagegen habe der Patient über Profen eingenommen, 600 mg.
Und der über Profen lindere die Schmerzen.
Aber es ist auffällig, dass der Patient seit 2 Tagen 10 Tablette über Profen eingenommen habe.
Und er fühle sich feber, aber habe das Feber, sein Feber nicht gemessen.
Und er gab an, unter Schüttelefrost zu leiden.
Und er berichtete, dass er unter Kaltschweizn bei der Schmerzattacken leide.
Und diese Beschwerden seien erst mal bei ihm aufgefallen.
Aufgetreten.
Und er gab an, er ist übel.
Und deswegen habe er 2 Mal Erbruschen.
Der Erbruschen habe unverdautes Essen gesächen.
Und deswegen habe er seit 2 Tagen nicht gegessen.
Das heißt, er leidet unter Inapätenz wegen Schmerzen.
Und auch wegen Schmerzen leidet unter Erbruschen.
Er habe Probleme mit Wasserlassen.
Er habe das Gefühl, dass er ein drinnen das Gefühl beim Wasserlassen.
Und er sagte, dass er ein drinnen dunkel geworden sei.
Und er müsste öfter auf die Toilette gehen.
Und ein halber, nochmal bitte.
Der Urin ist dunkel.
Er hat kein Problem mit Schulbanken.
Und er ist nicht sauer.
Er trinkt sehr selten Alkohol beim Feiern.
Er hat keine Erkrankungen.
Als Kind würde er Ponsselectomiert sein.
Und in der Familie haben sie sich ergeben beim Vater und Mutter.
Bei der Mutter, Arturale Hiperton und Diabetimellitis.
Und er nehme Ibuprofen,
600 Milligramm Beiber gegen Schmerzen.
Er sei Programmier und wohne allein.
Und sei ledig.
Er habe keine Kinder und kein Drogen genommen.
Die anerbändischen Angaben deuten am Erhisten auf ein Pylonephritis hin.
Dafür kann ich die Schmerzen in der rechten Bauchseite lassen.
Und in den Leisten und in den Drücken ausstrahlenden Schmerzen.
Und Übelkeit in Nausea und Hermes.
Könnte es auch eine Nierenstein sein?
Ja, es könnte auch sein.
Wir können jetzt alternativ kommen.
Ürolitiasis, Sistitis oder ja, wie kann man sagen, Ülnstein.
Nefolatieren.
Nefolatiasis, Impragen oder Gasparentitis.
Kann das auch eine Scholezistitis sein?
Ja, weil die rechte Bauchseite stehen.
Kann sein.
Ich kann auch beides haben.
Man hat nicht mehr einen Dunkelurin, wenn man eine Nierenstein hat.
Oder wenn man eine Pylonephritis hat, hat man nicht immer einen Dunkelurin.
Man kann das haben.
Trinkt ihr genug oder trinkt ihr wenig?
Wenig, weil ein Liter Wasser wenig.
Trinkt ihr wenig Wasser?
Kann auch eine Art.
Wenn die Zähne es haben?
Ja, alternativ kommen.
Die Vertikulitis?
Die Vertikulitis ist die linkste Seite.
Hat mich verstanden?
Gibt es rechts keine Vertikulitis?
So wird ich weiß nicht.
Gibt es schon, aber sieht man die Vertikulitis links?
Normale Vertikulitis können wir rechts haben.
Okay, egal.
Was machen Sie denn mit den Patienten jetzt?
Ja, so werde ich den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Und dann ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Als Blutwerte möchte ich zum Beispiel der Blutbild, Blutzucker
und Entzündungsparameter, Liebbarwerte, Nierenwerte
und Übrungsstatus auch wichtig.
Und Studiagnostik vielleicht?
Ja, um Abkustoritätsauszuschließen vielleicht.
Ja, in der Notaufnahme trauen Sie gar nicht Studiagnostik zu machen.
Also, das dauert zwei Tage, ne?
Ja, das nicht.
Wir müssen akut eine Entscheidung treffen.
Okay.
Ich möchte eine Bekannung verschreiben, um eine akutte Herzklankheit
auszuschließen.
Und auch unbedingt möchte ich Ultraschalldosenografie des Abdormens
oder Pannei-Thirda und so weiter.
Ultraschalldosenografie.
Und Röntgenvorrag und Röntgenabdormen
möchte ich auch durchführen.
Wenn Sie machen, müssen Sie aber nicht machen.
Ich würde erst mal Ultraschall machen.
Ultraschalldosenografie.
Und Röntgenabdormen.
Wenn der kein akutes Abdormen hat,
müssen Sie das nicht machen eigentlich.
Ja, genau.
Ja, das war es.
Und Sie gehen von einer Pyrotechnik aus.
Was haben Sie für eine Pyrotechnik?
Zuerst müssen wir den Patienten stationär aufnehmen
und dann Flüssigkeit verabreichen,
erst mal den Zuckern des Gefäßes.
Und dann Flüssigkeit verabreichen.
Und dann als symptomatisch
eine Terepalsyntomatisch geben wir zum Beispiel Antie an Anergetika und Antipyretika vielleicht
nochmal bitte. Was würden Sie geben als Weltsmedikament?
Paracetamol überprüfen und aspirin.
Iberpuffin, okay, falsche. Iberpuffin, intravenous gibt es nicht.
Okay, und dann Paracetamol.
Novalgin gibt es auch.
Novalgin. Und dann, aber die Früsigkeit zuvor ist sehr wichtig.
Ja, was noch?
Wenn wir brauchen, können wir auch Antibiotika anfangen.
Wenn Sie die Patientenstationär aufnehmen?
Warum nehmen Sie die Patientenstationär auf?
Nur um Früsigkeit zu geben oder Früsigkeit nicht auf Zuhause trinken?
Oder, das ist eine sehr, oder ja, ich nehme den Patientenkurskritiker auf, bis ich die Diagnose bestätigen kann.
Okay, Sie haben die Diagnose bestätigt. Was machen Sie mit den Patientenstationär?
Ich nehme die Patientenstationär auf, weil die Ursachen des Pylonephitis, ich könnte zum Beispiel
eine Bakterieninfektion, Bakterieninfektion, muss sein, deswegen müssen wir Antibiotika geben.
Genau, richtig, richtig, genau. Super.
Und selbst, würden Sie geben, wissen Sie das? Oder wissen Sie das nicht?
Als Promiss sind Sie vielleicht nicht?
Als Promissin, ja.
Also, die Propflexation zum Beispiel, oder?
Ja, die Knorlampe.
Die Knorlampe.
Ja, sehr gut. Okay.
Gibt es sonst Fragen oder Anmerkungen?
Das Herr Dacht, die Appnodist, Pylonephitis oder andere?
Pylonephitis, nepholutiasis, kann beides sein, weil, muss man überlegen, was er haben könnte.
Das kann man hier noch nicht ganz genau sagen. Aber es klingt so eher nach Pylonephitis.
Ja, danke.